good good  [Music]  can we help you with  this uh  [Music]  foreign  shots fired  [Music]  drop the gun  foreign  [Applause]  [Applause]  here  I'm grabbing his ID I'm going his wallet  check his ID  yeah we're good  he's gone  located next to the subject was a 40  caliber Smith and Wesson semi-automatic  pistol subsequent investigation revealed  that the three spent casings were  covered in The District 5 station match  the firearm recovered from the suspect  the subject's gunfire caused damage to  the District 5 Lobby and front office  area  this investigation is still ongoing and  due to an abundance of caution is being  led by the Milwaukee area investigative  team with the West Allis Police  Department as the lead agency